if that boy starts crying no baby we are
back with another episode we just
finished playing Age 2 trivia to follow
up on last weekly just now by the way
the comments are always flooded with day
ever since we talked about the podcast
you guys are the banks in the chat and
HQ but I got to q9 and I'm really proud
of this a new record
did you ever play Mario Party no record
record what is your code in case people
want a free life I don't know your thing
no mine is Julian solo so but people
have given me free life Wow what's your
name on the app I think it's jenna
Marbles that's it people
I think that's expected Falls to that
but regardless I have a bunch of free
lives I think you guys have been giving
me lives I was just so excited cuz that
when I signed up it was like the first
time in years that I signed up for a new
thing and somebody some little twirl
didn't take jennamarbles you know we
were like only a couple of a couple of
games in I think this podcast is brought
to you by wink dot try wink time sausage
annejulien
it's a service that gives you wine
delivered to your door guys delicious
wine customized for your mouth I could
go for some link right now I could go
for some link well then listen to this
I'm not gonna listen to that try wink
talk calm sausage Angela you get twenty
books off your first order you take the
palette profile quiz they gather
information about your palate specific
to you and then they send you wine that
they know you'll like they're experts
it's awesome also brought to you by that
is so gross that's so [ __ ] gross get
out of here live calm slash vagina and
Julianne lift guys it's a great way to
make some money whether on the side or
if you need your job you choose your own
hours
and right now if you lift comments ly
ft.com / annejulien you get a $500 new
driver bonus keep them you keep all the
tips lyft is one of the best it's the
best ride sharing platform out there
okay and they need drivers and ding for
him if you want to drive for lives I
suggest you do that because it's an
awesome opportunity the mic is going to
stay as far he's done looking good
shivering and she's chewing on something
but is that peachy what's in your mouth
peach
what is that oh it's from her bone oh
she like pull off a whole strip of it
gross you need Jesus no he needs Jesus
no we just got back from Portugal like a
couple nights ago literally not last
night but the night before so we're like
still pretty jet-lagged and blowing out
of it and me and Connie have been
inseparable since I got home he just
wants to be with his mommy he's been
crying so loud like kind of non-stop
yeah cuz he just like if there's a law
and attention he just needs some that's
right there's miss us I love my baby I
missed you so much
we need to be with each other and he
needs to like his mommy like anymore no
no no do you not encourage it I will not
allow it
you're even weirding him out what No
anyway what did you think of Portugal
cuz we just went to Lisbon for five days
and like he said we're pretty jet like
look last night I was laying in bed it's
weird cuz I'm like I'm pretty okay for
most of the day I'm kind of tired but I
get in bed and I feel like like a ton of
bricks just hit me in the head and I
feel like I ran ten miles so where does
feeling I just feel like completely
exhausted yeah I just felt like so
hungry because we didn't like nothing
against Portugal at all but it is not
the like semi vegan friendly but like
really not that gluten-free friendly
like we couldn't find a lot of stuff to
eat so when we got home I was exhausted
like in the middle of the day
when we woke up yeah had a hard time
falling asleep Friday when we got we got
back at like 11 p.m. Friday night or
something so it was a weird whole
midnight yeah midnight that was a weird
night for sleeping and then Saturday I
was like okay then exhausted at 3 p.m.
and then couldn't sleep but like 2 a.m.
you know and I just been so hungry
because we didn't have like enough
calories like this week this yeah are
you leaving me please no don't leave is
that miss not here boy but this morning
I did wake up and Julian had on his
Christmas pants so I was like I'm gonna
one-up you and put all whole Christmas
outfi you know I'm so festive already I
like love that were already this part of
the year yeah that's exciting
I feel like I'm falling victim to the
every year you just get more and more
excited earlier and earlier and I feel
kind of stupid but I also don't care
let's put the Christmas tree okay I read
like a stupid Twitter moments that was
like all the people in the UK like it so
excited early about Christmas which I
never even thought about because after
Halloween which didn't really super care
about they don't have those so it's like
the only thing they look forward to I
get it now I did
why so Ella is selling me Christmas
things mid October through December I
get it now I just never thought about it
cuz I'm dumb yeah speaking of zoella you
did a panel with Alfie yeah and Web
Summit how was that for you cuz that was
like for me watching that it was it was
really cool it was a proud moment but it
was also very interesting that sort of
platform with all these professionals in
the tech and business world yeah gather
in Portugal and year on the stage in the
arena not like a little venue like this
is like a concert or in concert sized
arena that you were speaking on what was
that like um I mean it was a little
weird
honestly I've done a couple things like
that where it's very corporate in a way
um the last one which was I want to say
twenty fourteen or fifteen or something
when we must have been 14 when we
announced my Sirius XM show
VidCon with Susan with Susan Wood's
Nikki whoa chicky whoo I swear on my
life used to have an end in her name I
swear Mandela effect I swear and then I
looked at her Twitter and I was like
what is the end and you name whatever so
I did it was a back when VidCon used to
be Thursday was business day Friday was
VidCon Saturday's VidCon Sunday was like
people go to Disneyland but also VidCon
and now it's like even last year it
[ __ ] like opening show was on a
Wednesday and I'm like editing my video
and they're like watch watch VidCon live
but I'm like [ __ ] I'm not [ __ ] there
yet
since when does VidCon start on a
Wednesday anyways this was back when
Thursday was strictly a business day so
I was there day early to announce on
stage because although you know it was a
YouTube and SiriusXM collaboration I'm
still waiting for YouTube to like maybe
pretend like this exists for the last
three years hello I'm doing a [ __ ]
YouTube themed radio show over here on
Sirius XM but less like three years
alone I mean they did make a big deal
about it you'd think that they like it's
a mutually beneficial thing but no well
it's really great I like it a lot
anyways so I went up on stage and it's
it was even more like it's supposed to
be like a fun happy exciting environment
it's VidCon
yay like people are announcing lots of
new cool fun exciting things so we walk
into it was not nearly the same sized
crowd like maybe half that size crowd or
less and Susan bless her had on a
beautiful dress and was just doing her
best I think she had just become very
recently she was appointed as CEO it's
not like she wasn't obviously she's been
there it was her first job ever actually
yeah so she's up on stage we tell she
was kind of nervous and I just kept
being like yeah today remember cuz you
had me vlogging for you
and I was I remember you said you said
something along the lines of like damn
Susan you look at nice she was like
thank you yeah she got real flustered I
was trying to just like loosen her up a
little he'd uh but uh it's just that
weird crowd environment where it's like
so it reminded you of that yeah or like
remember when we are in Japan and I had
a wonderful time in Japan but like
there's a language barrier so most of
the people in the audience we're
actually listening to someone verbally
translate what I was saying but they are
also super respectful and quiet during
our entire like Q&A panel type of thing
but it's like whenever you're in a room
full of people but like no matter what
you say there's like absolutely no
reaction you're like sick dude
so it was a little bit like that but I
think most of that was because clearly
when we looked at like the panel of
people we were there to sort of like
lighten the mood on purpose you know
it's like these very serious tech CEOs
you have politicians from all over the
world just like a fluid you guys
followed an interview with like one of
the heads of Google Europe yeah so in
that conversation was very serious and
informative that's a good conversation
so like the lack of the lack of response
from the crowd like did that like you
just feel weird or did you respect it I
expected it and in that way it also it
feels less of like like you can just sit
there and talk which is nice that's a
relief you feel maybe more heard totally
and you don't have to perform or like
make sure anybody's like being lively
where's if you if you're in front of a
crowd of like you know when we do a
school appearance so people are excited
and yeah you know they can get things
out or it'll ask questions or whatever
they want there's no rules it's been a
minute since I've had a crowd engagement
where it's everyone's sitting politely
and just listening to you you have to
say well it felt to me because I'm a big
fan of Olympic weightlifting and I
watching the Olympics and I also watch
like you know qualifiers and stuff and
it reminded me of that because those are
always in the giant arena but the stage
is so tiny and there's always such a
little golf clap and it's like so
respectful and very your
p and i guess because you know it's like
a ton of different countries you know
there and that's what it felt like
because it was like you would say
something or alfie would say something
or the interviewer would ask something
and you talk about something and if
there was a need for it there would be
like a little bit of a clap or a little
bit of a noise and then at the end it
was like very respectful like right
response but it was definitely new and
it was cool it was cool because I did
feel like you guys got to talk yeah it's
just a different environment that's
conducive to you speaking and being
heard and the lack of interaction with
the crowd doesn't necessarily mean that
people aren't enjoying what's being said
you know yes
like sometimes in our what we do for a
living is like if there's no response
it's bad but in that situation it's not
bad but it is different and I think it's
good that you were able to separate like
the fact that maybe just because there
wasn't screams and laughs that doesn't
necessarily mean it was like a bad thing
like you were able to adjust your music
I know no I know I'm just I'm telling
you that I thought it was impressive
that you were able to stay dialed in
regardless of like the different sort of
environment because it felt like you
know could someone who's used to doing
college appearances in VidCon well I
thought would have easily been like I
don't know maybe doubting themselves
when they got there and there's like
nope there's no yelling or whatever it's
not the yelling it's the like they're
evil laughs they're like ladies and
gentlemen welcome to the stage Alfie
deyes and Jenna Marbles and he's just
like yeah a lot of people I was
literally like 6,000 before in that room
how many people are in there there was
probably way more than 6000 I don't know
it looks like 5060 but they're all just
like sitting there like even even when
we got there and we're in like the
backstage like speakers prep area or
whatever I just like looked around like
I was wearing a sparkly sequined sweater
it was super cute but it's like
something I would wear you know to be
covered up and but also a little formal
Bullock also I'm here to Sparkle and
have a good time and every single person
that we were around is in this just like
very business list all black all maybe
blue everybody's wearing a blazer
everyone's wet like everyone looked
exactly the same and like being very
quiet there's like food errors being
like
so corporate and I literally I just
wanted to do a cartwheel through that
room so badly it didn't seem like
anybody was having like a lively good
time which probably means at night those
people go [ __ ] nuts yeah that's what
we were talking about where there's like
everyone's so straight-laced that you
know that crazy [ __ ] goes down in knots
at night the ties get loosened up the
liquor gets flowing and the mistakes get
made you know it I dunno it but it was a
it was a really good experience and
being in Portugal was like [ __ ]
magical is one of the most beautiful
places I think we've ever been and every
person that we met literally this was
their first like response it was like hi
how are you what's so exciting to meet
you how are you enjoying Portugal no
have you been to this place I do you
have to get a good place to eat or like
this like even our our uber drivers our
cab drivers they'll all like tour does
they all were every time we pass by a
building they would tell us everything
about it no tell us the style it was
like who built it like when it's from in
different parts of town
it was it was very much like everyone
there was really proud of Portugal and
wanted us to love Portugal as much as
they loved Portugal which was really
special yeah it was very cool everyone
was very nice I can't get over how
beautiful that city is it's ridiculous
the houses the colors of the houses just
the whole entire aesthetic of the city
yeah it was lovely surprisingly
beautiful for me and I expected a
good-looking city but lumière waters so
nice and thank you for taking me on that
trip with you that was fun
yeah thanks for going you're the best
but we're definitely jet-lagged we had
to eat some pizza to make up for our
lack of good eats hmm we did find some
good vegan gluten-free stuff there was
like one bakery near us that had some
treats that we could have but they
really only had like this sugary like
donut thing and then croissants and like
you can't really survive for that
otherwise you like yeah you need
something or on your dress on
but no it was like and then the torre de
belem was cool yeah it was cool I mean
they took took
[ __ ] a man what's with you guys
everywhere we go where there's like
tuk-tuk so you guys always want to take
a tuk-tuk what's fun it makes me crazy
you need to just like enjoy that though
I did for a little bit and then he got
lost and we were on that thing for like
45 minutes like 25 30 27 27 minutes you
know and it was freezing and I had
eyelashes on it was fun I was in the
middle yes I was wrong it was terrifying
we went on the highway he drove a little
too fast a couple points but it was
still really fun and I'm I'm defined fun
fun you're going you're driving with
other real vehicles at low speeds
you're on three wheeler it's a beautiful
sunset you're in a foreign city is that
enough like it felt like we were
drifting there were a couple if he turns
and and maneuvers but something just
gotta get your freak on I think that oh
my god I hate you so much I really I
didn't want to go on the tuk-tuk I got
talked into it and I didn't like any
minute of it I didn't I didn't like it
but he got lost and then we had to go
all the way back to where we came from
and then go back again mm-hmm thanks
Julian you're welcome you you're welcome
I paid for that took imagine how much
that took took could have made if it was
a lyft driver though
like so much in the tip would have been
off the charts because such a fun ride
and that's what you can do right now if
you become a lyft driver you go to Li
ft.com slice and julienne you get a $500
new driver bonus and you get a new job
okay you're gonna sign up a list of the
drivers you literally turn your car into
the workplace you clock in when you want
to clock in you go to work you pick
people up and thank you this has nothing
to do with you you were the one who said
let's go on and talk to man sorry about
that guy's just trying to talk about the
best ride sharing platform out there you
earn a hundred percent of the tips that
you make on your rides they they add up
over 200 million dollars have been
earned and since the tips were
introduced into the app they have
color-coded amp signs so when you're
driving your lyft and your customers
waiting right there they see your color
and it's easy to connect and can connect
is what you'll be doing with a list
because lyft drivers are known for being
nice and personable and having
interactions
I take lifts all the time and I enjoy
talking to the drivers and having them
be wonderful and it's a great experience
and if you're driving for lyft the my
opinion the greatest part is that you
make your own hours so you can clock in
whenever you want turn it into driver
mode make a couple bucks and make some
tips and then head on with your day
whatever you're doing it's a great gig
and you get a five is our new driver
bonus when you go to lift calm that's ly
ft calm / Jenna and Julian you won't be
sorry okay join the ride sharing
platform that treats their drivers right
also wink guys what a great service that
is I mean think about it if you're like
us and you want to just chill on an
entire Sunday or an entire Saturday or
entire Monday or whatever day you have
off and you want wined but you don't
want to go anywhere or see anyone just
go to wink they literally get the exact
type of wine scientifically engineered
for your mouth you take a power profile
quiz it's very easy couple questions
online
you gotta try winks commas TOI winc calm
Sasha and Julien you get $20 off your
first order so you take the profile
palette profile quiz they then save that
information so they're like do you like
dark chocolate you're like yes and
they're like okay that's factored into
our decision to why we're gonna give you
and so they send you wine they send you
wine that is selected from their team of
experts who know wine unlike me and
probably most people who go to the store
and pick the cool-looking label doesn't
really work out that well for me so you
go to wink alright they send you the
right to your front door and it's an
awesome service and you're gonna enjoy
it it's an awesome thing
thank you wink Thank You sponsors what
are you looking at me like that what did
I do
really really you don't know what you
did no don't talk to me or my son again
I wasn't gonna talk to yourself okay
he's not even looking at me he's being
very standoffish don't talk to that son
either all right so that son has a
Christmas shirt on too
he's very handsome so what we're gonna
do now is spoiler alert if you have not
watched stranger things too we are going
to talk about it so now is your moment
that you have to turn off the podcast if
you do not want to be spoiled we are
definitely going to be giving some
spoilers because we're gonna be
answering some discussion questions that
I gathered from a website business
insider they had an article about it hey
could you not do that that's like really
annoying don't do that to my boy oh you
did it you the one who showed me that he
slapped the bottom of my foot we used to
do that in softball it was like wouldn't
it hurt your hands at the cleats get out
no no like as a my friends started it
because she thought it was so funny but
then we started doing it year after year
on our spring training trip we would
convince people to face their fears and
let someone slap the bottom of their
heart if it feels terrifying if you've
never had it done
you're like I'm gonna slap the body of
your foot it's hard as I can and it
feels so scary and then when someone
does it really is it really desert that
bad imagine getting this part tattoo how
fast with that rub off all right we
talked about some two things - can you
put the Joe's down no he wants to sit
with me I'm his mommy don't ever talk to
me or my son again okay so we have some
discussion questions so if you've seen
two stranger things - or you don't care
about being spoiled sit with us and
answer these questions with us in the
comments or in your brain or on Twitter
okay so we're gonna start from the top
okay she's gonna go through these
questions I'm ready
can the shadow monster break the gate
between the upside down and the real
world I say yes because the power
doesn't hurt Dart
well the dart dart is an extension of
shadow monster yes but that's an example
of the shadow monster breaking the
extension between the upside down in the
real world
dart existed in the real world but it
could have been because of well because
dart didn't dart emanate from being
inside whale's body I don't know
remember when he coughed it up at the
end of season one oh yeah that was gross
that's art I don't know maybe it was
dark feeling that was dark but even
still he crossed into the world I feel
like people in the comments are gonna
get like you guys don't know the blood
come on we're just doing our best here
guys come on Bremen - it's too much
don't be don't be stranger things
purists okay we're just having a
conversation here but I don't think
they're gonna elitists no well it's just
I mean obviously I think they can break
the the gap because either either
they're capable of breaking the gap or
once the gap has been broken at all by
like any human than any way that anyone
can yeah right that's what I think all
right well I think that's because dart
existed in the real world which means
that others could if they could find
like if you think about it like so
they're able to dig into the
and they can go exist in the tunnels
like light it on fire and [ __ ] like that
they like even in season one they found
in a tree they could go and climb
through to the other side er the in
theory that could go both ways since the
people had gone back from the upside
down into the real world again so maybe
they could just cross through the gate
and exist in the real world or even in
the lab where they're all the demo dogs
are running around I was yeah I was
surprised how quickly and conveniently
they access the upside down in season 2
yeah everyone was just like I'm gonna
hop in for a little bit and go [ __ ]
exploring oh yeah where's that was the
entire premise of season was that
someone got stuck yeah whatever but I so
I guess the question and more
specifically is can the shadow monster
transition into into the real world is
that the question I say in 30 listen
yeah it's big enough at the end the gate
was pretty big when 11 was closing it
but the shadow monster is [ __ ]
massive yeah which I feel also looks
very flexible so maybe just his leg can
fit 2 and then a little bit it gets
bigger so he can wiggle his um
cylindrical shape body through it to you
know like a octopus like an octopus they
can fit in small spaces and the very
smart and clever octopi mm-hmm anyway
well the next question is will the
upside down slash shadow monsters ever
affect people outside of Hawkins and do
why is no one outside of the town
knowing about it
yeah see that was why I think so I
realized that a lot of people were
angrily tweeting on Twitter like stop
stop talking about stranger things
potholes and like just enjoy it like
shut up like that when they were doing
that whole thing towards like the climax
of season 2 yeah I was like why don't
they get in a [ __ ] car gather all of
them together go get a hotel and stay
somewhere outside of Hopkins like shell
for a little bit fam [ __ ] relax until
11:00 comes around
leave little yeah but you have to buy me
I think I understand both sides of that
argument you have to kind of like buy
into it a little bit yeah totally but I
do think that in theory again that it
can all exist outside of Hawkins well
season three just started in Hopkins
yeah and season three is definitely
going to expand this whole story past
Hawkins because of all the news tapes
that were sent out and the fact that the
spotlight was on the like it said five
months later or whatever yeah but still
like I'd be interested to see how far
they take it because you don't want the
show to get goofy like that's kind of
what happened to Heroes yeah I feel like
it's just they expanded it too much and
then it was not a long there's two big
the controller yeah then it's not your
lovely group of you know it's just like
the world against the monsters which is
every story ever yeah but I also well it
also it becomes like more and more
far-fetched that our beloved characters
would have anything to do with the
demise of the evil premise yeah you know
but I also Wow on the topic of Hopkins
in like the time period I just want like
I'm such a [ __ ] fan of this show and
like I think they do such an incredible
job with like everything that goes into
portraying this this town in this time
like the 80s the the costume design is
amazing like the Wardrobe is so [ __ ]
OnPoint the music is so [ __ ] OnPoint
I'm like such a big fan of like visually
and everything else like the show is so
good I'm just a huge fan just wanted to
say that in case you thought I hated it
is is there anyone left to go hunting
for 11 like his dr. brenner alive or
dead or if he's dead is there anyone
else that papa papa
yes I think Papa's alive I think pop is
definitely alive like what else would
the purpose be if he was dead well if he
was dead they were the yeah it's like
what are they gonna wait til season like
season 2 of he's nowhere and then season
3 they're just like oh yeah by the way
he's dead like no yes definitely
back yeah I think he's coming back and
is he going to try to get 11 back or in
can he put up a fight like she's at an
all-time high with her powers mm-hmm she
connected with her sister mm-hmm
there could be many more of them right
are there more of them yeah well she's 8
and 11 is 11 there's probably a 12 and a
13 and it's a little math formula that
got them those are the only two numbers
by the way I really liked that girl's
character
yeah me too and I also like that she had
different powers like so what are the
other powers are they like since eight
powers are you know she can make people
see things or think them or believe them
and 11s are ver a lot more powerful
their kinetic or physical if she can
move things she has telekinesis and
[ __ ] she can see things like would
her successor like a huge she's living
there please would like a 12 or 13 what
the [ __ ] are their powers yeah I think
they also obviously sent around the mind
mm-hmm be cool to know like what those
are though but then again like I feel
like that needs to be treaded lightly
because there they go too crazy then
it's just the x-men right yes so she's
like Jean Grey or whatever and then you
have another person that comes in and is
Magneto
oh yeah it's gotta be careful it's a
fine line you're walking with this well
even the the group of characters around
8:00 we're a little likely sure all
right guys like don't make it cheesy
like you're taking it is turning it into
every other superhero thing and not like
what we fallen over the show for which
is and I think I don't wanna let you
finish that sentence well we loved it
because it was a group of kids that were
you know doing the impossible together
by being giant nerds and adorably lovely
and amazing yeah and now you've turned
it into a riff raff crew of people who
have wrong then ditched by society out
to avenge people
kill them and I'm proud of 11 for not
joining that but like we've seen that
band of characters before yeah and I
believe that there was some criticism I
think that was episode 7 I believe there
was some criticism of that episode
because mainly of that and I completely
understand that and I relate to that
that point of criticism where it's like
the group was very very over-the-top
little cliche and also like unnecessary
to the storyline like you could have had
11 go on this tangent by herself with
his journey meeting her sister and
whatnot without any of that it would've
just been like two girls or whatever but
I will say that the rest of episode 7
and the fact that it was sort of an 11
episode I didn't mind that I kind of
liked that it was like her own isolated
little side story if you will within the
bigger plot and I enjoyed it because it
gave it gave me a little more than just
eleven saving the rest of the kids asses
and Hawkins over and over right because
that that gets all but I also feel like
some day when we look back on stranger
things
we'll see season two is this like
exhausting alright get 11 back together
with the cast already season you know
yeah because in my opinion if the if she
didn't go on that journey she would have
just like nullified all the problems
that were they were having at Hawkins
yeah I wouldn't have been really any
conflict because 11 could have been
there preventing it all the whole time
yeah and it wouldn't have led to that
beautiful moment of Mike and 11 meeting
each other again at the end I know I'm
adopting her yeah yeah but it was also I
was confused
obviously 11 was gonna live after season
one but like did they really clarify
that she didn't just like shatter into a
billion pieces
oh I was I was on the fence I didn't
know what was going on leading into
season two I mean obviously she's still
in it because you see her doing all the
pressur of the show and did we really
get justice for barb though did we
really hmm not really because they had
to fake the funeral but it was still a
fake reason gonna let it be nice to max
already
we don't need on this girl-on-girl I
like it I like that strife [ __ ] I do
not like be nice to Meg's
oh my god she appeared to visit Mike to
see what he was up to and he's in the
gym with some girl 11 I'm not blame her
11 News patty dot-com 11 is here right
here for 11 times 11 is patty calm
that's why I'm here she's a petty [ __ ]
call her a [ __ ] okay she's the patty
patty patty yeah oh she's ready Betty
literally nothing wrong with being petty
I'm petty all the time my name is patty
calm 11 is patty calm max did nothing
except move to a news go and make a
group of new friends it was also really
petty yeah it was also really important
that she walked in because he legit like
Mike hates max so there was like one
moment where he wasn't yelling at her
and elevenses that one moment 11 patty
calm this discussion are death no we
were talking earlier I think other
people were too but we are also trying
to save Twitter and stuff because we
didn't finish it until like yesterday we
saved it for the plane not to Portugal
and back so that we could have something
to watch so we did waste some time but
um max is older brother what is this
character's name Billy I was just going
to talk about him out yeah we were
talking about how they needed to
introduce someone more dislikable than
Steven City lines so we like Steve now
we're normally breakout actor and season
1 though yeah but I definitely know we
all like Steve a lot I yeah and I
definitely appreciate you Steve you can
do better
literally Steve season this season was
Nancy got drunk and yelled at him at a
party and then he just like slows around
also but now he's like he's like this
stupid lovable guy he's like not very
bright but he's also so sweet and he's
taking care of the kids and he's like
that storyline in a nutshell my
girlfriend gets drunk in a party tells
me she doesn't love me and then I just
sulk for the rest of the season until I
like somebody with a bat but even in the
beginning I get my ass beat yeah but
even in the beginning of the season
before any that happened in the car when
they're talking about college and he
he's just kind of like he's like a dud
you know that that relationship isn't
going anywhere and you knew what it was
all I'm saying is that it's funny to
think about that that's isn't
season yeah Manny got his ass beat I
said yeah but he also did whoop some
demet hock true but his storyline is my
girlfriend it's drunk at a party tells
me she just loves me I soak around I get
my ass beat and then I take this at the
little middle school to a problem he
also gave me a super which you know next
season that's gonna happen with Billy
like they're gonna make Billy likable
somehow okay as he's already on his way
there and we don't even know his
backstory true I mean I that whoever
plays that character is a fantastic I
was saying not the other day I was like
I [ __ ] love this guy
yeah Ray's a great character he's a
great person to hate but I agree with
you because he's so like that role is
really enjoyable even though they laid
around a little bit yeah the smoking
while he's working out but GQ posted his
audition tape for that role really and I
wash it and he's [ __ ] good yeah he's
great he's good he's fun to watch and
that whole back story with the abusive
dad and the stepmom and then the mom in
California oh yeah and he's hitting on
[ __ ] Nancy's mom or whoever's and
that was fun I love this is [ __ ]
gross no no I love that that was a good
pot moment I like that yet nasty and
then he gets in his car and he's like
hollandaise work like he's really not
even into it at all he's just like being
a [ __ ] skis ball yeah roads great it
was great it's fine I know it's good um
obviously max is gonna be more and more
like welcomed into the crew I just want
to know what's gonna happen to Billy you
know I'm curious about their their back
story another question did dart
intentionally save Dustin in the tunnel
at the end no darts stupid and likes
nougat we were on the plane when we
watch that and Julianne was like scream
laughing you were like screaming because
I blanking on that kid's name
Dustin yeah no his realized actor but
it's the same Dustin in the I'm just
yeah that's the character but he is
that dude is such a good talent Oh funny
and when he when he little under the
breath comments he does and the kind of
ad-lib II think it's like that gets me
like crazy he's like out of breath and
he locks the door and he's I'm sorry he
had so many great moments this is
amazing he's talking to his mom he's
like you're gonna go find her and I'm
gonna stay here just the casement all
right I love you
it's so funny he's really bad yeah
anyway yeah I don't know I don't know if
I want to believe that dart the save him
I think he know dart maybe recognize
this smell and was like I'd rather just
like eat new game Dobby is my friends
plus like at that point the the shadow
monster was already in [ __ ] trouble
so dart had no business being aggressive
anymore right it was like they're
they're on the verge of fleeing anyway
yeah I will be interested to see in
season 3 those my groin they were in the
tunnel and that big like valve sneezed
all over Dustin's your face that and on
on hopper to sneeze on hopper yeah yeah
what is that you see if that does
anything I don't think it'll do is like
what it did a little bit you know
speaking of will do you think will has
finally read his connection to the
upside down with that little exorcism
they performed I say no and I was Julian
was laughing really hard because during
one of those scenes where he's like tied
to a bed and like all the [ __ ] keeps
happening
I literally as like poor will man he's
gonna be so far behind in school like so
[ __ ] like I would I would be cool if
they for the next season
oh [ __ ] sorry my mom's trying to
FaceTime me not now you should go I
would be like totally cool if we'll just
got to be another character next season
like for [ __ ] sake
like not make it okay well yeah can you
not get tortured for one season and he's
like so adorable and a great actor like
can he pretend to be happier giver Nona
crying and worried and shade smoking and
[ __ ] all men I would not be upset if
they deviated from that storyline and
let him just like be one of the one of
the crew for a little while yeah like
even just the this stuff when you notice
like all the actors get to act on all
these scenes together and we'll so he's
just huddled in some blanket with Winona
Ryder for [ __ ] sake yeah he's like the
kid who is always sick yes I think they
will give that that arrest because they
don't want to over do that next season
I'm excited to see like what what the
connection becomes yeah well I mean even
if he still has a connection I feel like
I'd be more satisfied seeing him not be
like completely away from the rest of
the cast because of it yeah I mean we
don't really know how he interacts that
what like that much with his yeah we saw
him go trick-or-treating for five
seconds till he got knocked on his ass
and went upside down yeah and like in
the first season you barely saw him
interact at all because he was stuck the
whole I barely knew him alright last
question is there do you think there's a
way to destroy the upside down like
completely yeah like how how would you
say that's possible hmm probably just
love good you have to go down there you
have to put a bathroom mirror on the
wall you have to turn around three times
and then 11 and what's-his-face kiss in
the mirror and say they say stop it stop
it stop it three times Barbra Streisand
appears she sings a beautiful song and
then dedicates it to Barb and Sirius on
a more serious note what do you think
the point of that last shot was what was
the last shot where it's the school
dance and then it turns the camera
upside down and then there's this shadow
monster above this school in the upside
down what do you think the point that
was I think the point of it was the
gates closed but it's still there yeah I
agree and that it's all real time yeah I
agree
that's exactly what I was gonna say the
gates been shot but it's still all right
there yeah so I have a question because
I am
it just rusty on my season one but
basically the creation of 11 and her
telekinesis and all of that was what
opened up the portal in the first place
correct I think yes so if they've
introduced the premise of being chicken
or the egg right like I don't know I
thought that was the most God and she
was like I opened the gate I did this
maybe okay with her like mine that like
ripped a tear in the folder whatever
enough luck so with them introducing
eight yeah we have to presume maybe in
theory that there was someone that came
after her so if 11 opened this portal if
there was another person that they were
doing experiments with could there have
been it may be in another place around
the world or somewhere else that's what
I don't know there have been some other
type of force that was created or some
other entity that was created there
different upside-down some some some way
interact is current upside-down that
could then defeat it I desperately hope
that they don't go too crazy with
expansion in terms of like supernatural
oh yeah and like different different
subjects like number five number seven
like I don't want this to become like
that they this whole group of like
gifted test subjects who are now like
realizing their and I'm fine with the
sad story of them getting revenge on the
people who [ __ ] them earlier or
whatever but yeah I think it'd be cool
to see like what may be other
upside-down could look like our other
locations related to the upside down
could look like and how they would
interact with the Hawkins upside down I
just don't want to become this like
worldwide like now there's someone in
Japan who has a tattoo of number two in
their arm and they're like I can throw
cars at people I I just don't want to
become that but you don't want to be
excellent yeah I don't want to be x-man
we don't want at least eleven x-men I'm
fine with eight eleven and maybe like
one more yeah give me like two honestly
I would be cool if they haven't be like
a ginger no we already have a ginger we
have mags no like a little ginger boy a
Marlin like a Marlin I would be cool if
they just hear me out
Oh God drop the storyline of the upside
out altogether and it was just a show of
them being
marriage I would watch it I would watch
the [ __ ] out of that what if they get
that next season there once we just
think three and then it was just like
normal and nothing they still play the
music it was like to do it and then it's
just all them going to class and hanging
out I'd be cool with that I would tell
you sure did but if you're gonna go that
route I need like 15 seasons basically
make it big brother in organs weeks you
know just make it last forever
it's basically Hilary Duff but it's such
a good they're all the characters are so
well developed it's such a good story
and like that's how good it is I would
watch that yeah like that last scene
with them at the school dance or
whatever which by the way perpetuates
this [ __ ] level of disappointment
every time you see a school dance on TV
or in a television shower in a movie
where did they get the budget to
decorate the gymnasium like that [ __ ]
sake no it was there was like stuff
drape from the ceiling it wasn't just
like some balloons and a table with
punch and like your gym teacher is a
chaperone there was like lights and
drapes like it would cost you a fortune
to decorate that room like that it was
living hairs on realism I'm going for
the [ __ ] party scene when people are
doing keg stands in the 10th grade that
didn't happen ever
true true very true in my opinion the
school dance was appropriately decorated
I've seen school dances like that I mean
it wasn't a nice it really wasn't that
nice I I didn't think it was off at all
oh my god my school dances did not look
like that ever I mean ever ever ever
maybe for a small town as they portray
Hawkins to be a it's a little inaccurate
I don't think it's over-the-top look I
think high school are doing curls in his
living room while he smokes a cigarette
at the same time is more inaccurate than
the school day considering that where
the show appears to be portrayed looks
like relatively rural are you kidding me
with the budget for that Jim what is it
what do you think about getting a ladder
up in
getting lights and streamers from the
ceiling like on that scale is way too
much like your tiny little I am fine
then you then you can't just be 11 and
show up at our school dance it's gonna
be $10 a head I'm sure she paid no she
didn't and what is she you [ __ ]
student now what are you allowed in
school no date to the dance that doesn't
go to this school maybe high school only
yeah what rate is that child probably
nice night they stopped yelling so they
go to this they go to the same school as
Stephen them don't they do they know it
could be a middle high school it's a
ninth grade he's middle high school oh
my god it's not that's not even an
argument
it could be middle high school or it
could be high school I'm not okay again
going with the fact that where they look
like the show was portrayed in some
semi-rural place in Indiana or whatever
the [ __ ] I can't really tell they
probably have a middle high school like
everybody goes to school like that still
that doesn't give me any that's no
personal you're telling me those kids
are in high school I think I personally
think all of the kids in a little Rat
Pack like will Mike Dustin I think
they're 9th graders they're 9th graders
I think that's ridiculous
ninth ever you've gone to a high school
and seen high schoolers now they look so
young it's ridiculous when you were
there everyone looks so old and I was
like well there's like grown-ass men in
12th grade now it looks like like my
step-brother like when he first got into
high school he was tiny I was like
there's no way you're a high schooler
but he was it's like when you leave
everyone's am I the only one I'm sorry
I'm sorry
years after you finished high school you
go back and you look mean like Wow high
schoolers look so much younger than they
did when I was there that's a thing well
yeah you're an adult yeah but that's the
thing
that's a thing I don't think they're in
high school I think that they're in
middle school I think that they're in
like seven threes what do you guys think
is it and also is there evidence to
refute Jenna's claim or my claim are
they in high school or are they not
I think they're in high school I think
your youth grade I think every one
except for her I did not go
trick-or-treating in ninth grade
yeah I did I [ __ ] my trick-or-treating
what your [ __ ] no no they came to our
house and dabbed on us and said team ten
I'm not like them yes you are why cuz
you want trick-or-treating when you were
in ninth grade would you rather me
you've been going to get drunk at
parties well you don't have to get drunk
at parties but Alisha have friends I
know they're like watch scary movies
with or get free [ __ ] candy my god
we dressed up we weren't abusing the
system and at ninth graders not a
full-grown adult you're basically a
middle schooler don't coffin in the mic
11 is patty Daka okay well there you
have it
anyway 11 is a petty overall I love the
season I can't [ __ ] wait for season 3
but I know it's gonna be another year
regardless well done stranger things let
us know what you think in the comments
to any of its discussion questions we
hit and if we were wrong and how wrong
we are but maybe you don't be hard on us
cuz we're sorry
and don't forget object 11 is Peggy
thank you guys for hanging out for
another episode we'll see you guys next
week back here in our little dungeon
movie last jetlag foster heart
[Music]